s'il vous plaît est ce que vous seriez
prêt à accueillir une famille de
réfugiés ukrainien chez vous dites la
vérité bah franchement a rien à y en a
je vois les oui je n'y crois pas une
seconde à voir donc nous voilà non non
non oui vallée riche chez j'y crois pas
mais c'est pourquoi vous savez moi en
l'occurrence c'est le cas c'est en
contact avec une famille chrétienne dont
connaissez cdc des attaques à la cda
mills pas pareil je vous dis des gens
coup quand j'ai quand même pas
personnellement ce sont des collègues de
travail de mon compagnon parce que moi
sur italia à deux ans avant avant le coc
vide en ukraine dans près du dombass à
garçons pour pour pour faire une série
de documentaires et il a rencontré ces
deux familles et depuis on est
évidemment en contact avant on a repris
contact avec eux parce qu'ils avaient
plus de contacts depuis ces 2 de ce ce
travail et il aura évidemment proposé de
s'il arrivait à quitter le pays à
devenir chez nous et c'est de famille
que je ne connais pas guillaume non
alors à part valérie ou dormant stop à
la démagogie moi tout ce qui m'est oui
j'ai rien vous demandez quand à quelle
date vous accueillez une famine
ukrainienne chez vous parce que c'est
bien de mes tweets pour faire bien mais
si vous le préférez allemand ça ne sert
à rien c'est vrai et ensuite ce qui
m'exaspère à peu c'est qu'il ya une
forte mobilisation nous incitons nous
encourage à accueillir une famille
ukrainienne chez vous et je n'ai pas vu
le même engouement pour accueillir
d'autres réfugiés comme les réfugiés
syriens donc voilà ma réponse est non
désolé elle peut choquer mais on a pigé
oui tous vous pour vous êtes un peu
comment il faut accueillir tout le monde
à vous tous les riches et pourquoi alors
on entend les résines ça m'allait on va
parler avec géant messieurs dans un
instant guy vernet ou si vous êtes
prévoit alors je vous le dis très en
avance à tous
je vous le dis très honnêtement
personnellement non je l'aurais pas fait
mais grâce à ma compagne château qui
accueille plein de gens qu'un sens de la
générosité oui mais moi personnellement
je le dis sans alors mettez non à oui
mais pas du tout aimé parce qu'on peut
le faire parce qu'on est allé en clément
gare à vous oui moi je dis oui parce que
j'ai un appartement dans lequel je ne
vis pas et que je prête à chaque fois
qu'il ya un problème quand il ya eu les
crues historiques à agen il ya quelques
mois j'ai ouvert aussi n'est ce pas aux
sinistrés j'ai rien demandé donc et
après on dit les ukrainiens mais
honnêtement ça peut être les ukrainiens
ça peut être n'importe quel réfugiés
comme ça c'est très bien agencé quand je
le verrai à n'importe qui et je ne
demanderai rien en échange et non je
suis pas des mains gauches c'est que
c'est la réalité
béatrice non non je vais pas mentir que
j'ai pas la placer
donc non je vais pas faire semblant
c'est une question de place c'est une
question de m'appeler stéphane plaza
500 mètres carrés et un étage prêter
comme clément peut-être mais voilà j'en
ai pas très bon sac à main c'est non
voilà ce que j'ai pu la place si simard
est équipe une place dans sa vraie place
il a passé d'accord avec eux je trouve
ça assez révoltant de faire un choix sur
les sur les réfugiés effectivement là je
pourrai pas le faire entendre raison et
puis je pense qu'il faut avoir du temps
à consacrer on n'a qu'une mamie c'est ca
c'est un budget aussi que voient la main
des financièrement c'est assez un effort
mais met donc je ne serai pas besoin de
le faire j'aurais dit non c'est non
après je trouve que ben moi j'ai pas la
place non plus mais au-delà de ça moi je
trouve que c'est insupportable de
toujours donner des mauvais points aux
français de les culpabiliser en
permanence ce sens il ya eu quand même
un élan de solidarité extraordinaire il
ya des dons on peut donner des affaires
on peut donner d'une des soins de
premier secours je vois des gens qui
traversent la france entière qui
traverse l'europe pour aller chercher
des familles donc franchement on est
exemplaire et c'est pas vrai on a
peut-être moins mais on a aussi
accueilli des réfugiés syriens 5000 en
france alors c'est peut-être pas assez
c'est peut-être moins qu'en allemagne
mais on accueille aussi les réfugiés
d'autres d'autres nationalités alors que
par exemple je sais pas au qatar en
arabie saoudite ils en accueillent pas
donc je trouve qu'on n'a pas non plus de
le sang est bon qu'il dit ah non ça sent
les chiffres réels dangers et
malheureusement je trouve qu'on nous
donne trop à chaque fois des mots comme
si on était forcément raciste ou mauvais
c'est aussi parce qu'elle n'est pas
d'accord dieu mais j avais en tant que
bénévole je vous assure qu'on voit pas
la télé ni sur internet croyons et ont
pas directement sur le plan et ses
resserrement on reçoit énormément de
gens même de là où vous dites et non
vous citez des vis des pays soi-disant
qui a rien on fait énormément de choses
croyez moi maintenant je comprends qu en
france on reçoit du monde il n'y a pas
de problème qu'on les reçoit chez nous
on a déjà des gens à l'intérieur dans
france qui sont eux qui s'en sortent à
peine la peine c'est bien de cueillir
des gens qui en quelque part l'envoi
ressort pratiquement sans immigrés ou du
mois sans réfugiés qui vont arriver dans
pas longtemps sincèrement faut penser à
ceux qui sont ici déjà ceux qui s'ils
sont ils sont ici sincèrement et s'en
sortent à peine à peine ils ont la dalle
je sais de quoi je parle parce qu'en
france nous avons des français qui
effectivement qu'on croit qu'ils ont un
moyen de s'en sortir avec un rsa au
chômage aux portes aujourd'hui moi je
travaille en tant que bénévole et je
croyais m je sais de quoi je parle je
suis dedans je vois des gens qui
arrivent vraiment dans une sont cinq six
enfants même des failles sont que deux
cas vous savez c'est extrêmement
compliqué d de ceux qui sont essayés
déjà c'est très très sombres cela dit
ils sont bombardés barre cela dit pour
moi je parle du prince et on peut
recevoir des personnalités de
l'extérieur mais faut pas être hypocrite
en tant qu on peut recevoir ton menaçant
tout le monde est fermé on peut faire
des concessions en attendant voilà faut
regarder ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
avec ces sujets qui malheureusement pas
les la pologne qui veut pas recevoir
certains d'entre eux il faut faire un
effort d'en prendre il faut pas non plus
à en abuser parce qu'en france déjà on a
à peine à s'en sortir mais c'est
rarement
écoutez moi je suis d'accord avec la
deuxième partie de votre propos je suis
même assez surpris de vous l'entendre
dire parce que c'est exactement ce que
je vais vous quand vous donc il faut
savoir que des blancs ou des non non non
je dis bien des projets
dans un instant à ma j'espère j'espère
simplement que vous quand vous dites ou
est on est on a déjà des gens qui sont
tous vivre très difficilement chez nous
et c'est ce qui est très vrai j'ai
salagou est aussi le même raisonnement
quand il s'agit d'autres immigration et
pas simplement quand c'est une
immigration européenne et ukrainiennes
en l'occurrence donc j'espère ne vous
ait pas deux poids deux mesures quand à
dire là je rejoins géraldine maillet
excusez-moi l'arabie saoudite et le
qatar ne sont pas connus pour être des
terres d'immigration ils ont eu chaud
sur les millions de syriens qui ont fui
ils ont accueilli combien le même le
pauvre liban a accueilli deux fois plus
dix fois plus de syriens que des leriche
kata ou la très riche arabie saoudite
donc faut arrêter avec ça et je suis
d'accord on n'a pas de leçon à recevoir
maintenant c'est vrai que les réfugiés
ya deux catégories de réfugié si vous
voulez enfin il ya les réfugiés qui sont
de vrais réfugiés c'est à dire qu'ils
sont là pendant la période de la guerre
et une fois que la guerre est finie ils
rentrent chez eux ces réfugiés non alors
celle infligée à moi j'aime à point pour
les accueillir à partir du moment où
c'est temporaire or l'expérience montre
que les réfugiés en provenance du monde
arabo afro musulmans ne reparle jamais
chez eux par exemple qu'elle ne savait
pas là ne repart jamais chez eux
mais vous savez combien de civils et la
religion
c'est pas vrai visionner ce qu alors
collecter les ukrainiens d'abord je
tiens à préciser que les réfugiés
ukrainiens se sont ralliés c'est à dire
des femmes des enfants mais vieillit
dévier des vieillards qui veulent rester
à proximité de leurs ping principalement
en pologne la hongrie et c'est parce
qu'ils veulent être au contact de leurs
hommes mari frère etc ils sont eux sur
le front excusez moi ça a quand même une
petite différence avec les réfugiés que
nous accueillons du sud de la
méditerranée qui soit 99 % des hommes
moi j'ai jamais vu des pays en guerre où
les hommes fuyaient en laissant femmes
et enfants au front alors vous vous
pensez bien que c'est quand même pas la
même chose là ce sont de vrais réfugiés
et c'est vrai qu'on a moi j'ai vu des
images terribles ou des gens voilà passé
et d'autres pour leur couleur de peau ne
m'a sais pas mais c'est quand même moi
pour moi ça m'a savoir complètement
révolté ça pour moi c'est horrible je ne
comprends pas comment on peut faire un
tri à ce niveau là c'est quand même moi
je crois pour que j'ai halluciné quand
on m'en a parlé je croyais qu'il veut
sinon c'est impossible ça n'est pas vrai
et vous vous connaissez mon métier mais
ça c'est valable est ce que c'est ce que
le mot immigration choisie ça vous dit
quelque chose c'est juste une poésie
n'a pas de religion la fin juin c'est
juste une bolée du bétail la
flamme est pas laissée papa avait
ensuite je répondrai pas non non je dis
je dis je je dis juste que j'aime pays
arabes unis et je vois chaque pays
laissez moi parler de mener ses missions
il va finir après tout pays a le droit
de décider qui rentre et qui sort de
chez lui voilà encore une fois quand il
s'agit surtout surtout quand il s'agit
moi je suis français donc quand il
s'agit de pays qui sont pas français là
tout le monde comprend que ces pays là
peuvent accepter chez eux des gens qui
leur ressemblent bizarrement dès qu'il
s'agit de la france on lui dénie ce
droit alors moi je comprends pas moi je
dis que à partir du moment où ces
réfugiés ont moins de chance de repartir
en a le cfaa des réfugiés ni pas des
réfugiés non non c'est pas des réfugiés
ce sont des immigrés c'est à dire ce
sont des gens qui vont rester parmi nous
unir et on accueille chez nous non
seulement cela mais ressasser les
serrois finira s'agit gouverner moi on
accueille chez nous pas seulement des
gens qui peuvent vivre parmi nous il
faut accueillir chez nous des gens qui
peuvent vivre comme nous mais au rythme
et d'accessoires ont fait comme ans de
vivre ou des nanotubes à l'ensemble
c'est aussi savoir que vous dites alors
tableau a plus de chance de vivre comme
vous
devez le pas donné mais qu'est ce qui
fait qu'on
attendait mais qu'avant de montrabe vous
le découvrirez même
fcc bouquet
tv j'en ai
pour moi
laissez parler ces bombes laissez pas
parler 0 est pas d accord hors mis mes
jambes non je dis simplement que
effectivement les réfugiés s'est réfugié
en plaine sont deux fois il ya beaucoup
de réfugiés qui sont de forro figée que
fait l'ofpra office français de
protection des réfugiés d apparat mines
seront alors que julien la couleur elle
sélectionne non il ya des vérités en
baisse et un accord de la preuve c'est
que quand votre message malbouffe et 82%
de la raison tant de drames dossier
d'asile sont déboutés en retourne et
intelligent
la question enfin de la question de la
sélection mais il existe simplement
c'est les critères qui varie ses deux
jambes on va laisser me cymbales vous
répondre alors écoutez je vous dis un
truc hyper important and ukraine en ce
moment vous avez des blacks de couleur
black au type de couleur peu importe qui
sont venus que trina ils peuvent pas
aller en poste chez financé cette étude
sur les pratiques et rené quinton de
leur pays
[Musique]
par des français alors notre camion
c'est faire du sport vous êtes comme
garde-fou mais ce n'est pas grave
non justement ils savent aller c'est
même le raisonnement des failles que la
violence surgit nirmala gilles verdez
genlissiens très calmement là vous
franchissez des bandes c'est que oui
même vous je n'aurais jamais dire je
franchis débourser mois loi et 2008 vous
dites que vous légitimez le tri sélectif
est réfugié sélective les seat hamel
juste une plus ample grattoir vous
voulez ouvrir le pays affronte rcd prix
les
ressorts à des échelles et réfugiés
c'est jeudi il ya les bons et les
mauvais réfugiés pour ça je le font les
autres activités pvc le travail et vous
n'êtes pas à nous de protéger la terre
entière excusez moi mais vous pensez que
ces gens là qui tentent de fuir une
bière on a trié d'art autour des
algériens marocains sénégalais il ya des
pays qui sanaa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas
ces gens mais ça juste une question
extrêmement pragmatique extrêmement
pratique on a vu des flux de réfugiés
qui fuient leur ville qu'yves livres etc
énormément de villes qui sont peut-être
éminemment sous les bombes ou déjà sous
les bombes qui sont des ukrainiens
blancs noirs métis tout ce que vous
voulez et qui arrive à la frontière
polonaise à la frontière polonaise
visiblement on a vu les images se passe
une sorte de tri où on accepte les
blancs et roulé noir sont refusés sénat
patrick chesnais je suis non je ne lis
pas les gitans jeudi je n'ai pas aimé ce
que je peux alors allez vibrer pour tout
expliquer allez disons sans s'enflammer
dans un truc émotionnel bon même si la
situation s'y prête ce que je dis c'est
que chaque pays est responsable de ses
citoyens la france lorsqu'elle a des
citoyens menacés à l'étranger les yeux
que les français qui sont en ukraine par
exemple on n'a pas demandé à l'allemagne
de les évacuer la france a mis en place
ce qu'il fallait un pont aérien des
fronts les verts même parce que c'est
des français ah oui lorsque vous êtes
lorsque vous êtes d'autres nationalités
et bien c'est au pays mais non
je les ai perdu mon
fils il ya des noirs
finalement pour l'essayer mais comme
serait donc si la
crise ils ont des passeports craignant
bah oui dans ce cas ils peuvent passer
très bien
de quoi il ya des asiatiques
d'ukrainiens tant que vous y
allez vite fait pour la france où
correct
la france on est bien content d'avoir
désobéi
contraire si j'étais mieux toutes les
sociétés n'était pas bulle des sites
c'était pas bon faire
chapelle est très content d'avoir ça
c'est un procès d'intention suspense
avait tort non voudrais juste dire à
batman a évoqué 90 e j'aime afghan
l'acquis ceux qui sont obtenues au ray
et barbu qui veut qu'ils cherchent à
naples et vous pouvez les premiers chez
vous
ça vous parlez de moi c'est moi tu ris
al est alors allé à 13 me poser votre
candidature pour les habitués béatrice
village de sujets via le premier sujet
qui est dans un groupe donné qu'ils
arrivent à la frontière on ne peut pas
trier toi tu es blanc tu vas bien sûr
mais nous la joue par jour malaisie
malte mais ce sujet avec le monde aura
quelques jours exemple un journaliste
que j'aime beaucoup qui s'appelle
vincent hervouët qui parlent de la
guerre voilà dix ya 25 guerre dans le
monde on peut effectivement dire la
france ne peut pas accueillir tous les
révoltés des 25 guerre mais ce sont deux
sujets différents ont trié des gens au
faciès
contrôle pas le visage qui contrôlent
les papiers devront
contrôler si vous êtes vous si vous êtes
maroni 100 ukrainien ou ressortissant
d'un pays de l'union européenne c'est
parfaitement normal que vous soyez pas
prioritaire
il va y va aussi évacuer des personnes
d'autres nationalités des actes de non
c'est vous plaît s'il vous plaît allez
sortir alors franchement aller faire un
petit tour vous allez voir ce qui se
passe actuellement je pense que vous
êtes vous êtes dans le déni complètement
je vous assure il ne contrôle même pas
les papiers et voit le physique tu te
noies arabes des marais bête à la
frontière mais arrêtez de dire des
bêtises à jamais perdu quand vous faites
honte j'ai eu
96 tous vous assumez vous en tendant à
les îles bien mais oui je suis allé
justement jean vient en fait jean bien
moi je suis pas lassé de raconter des
conneries je vous assure mouvement
c'est un test moi-même shalit chez lui
trouver un écho évident que voilà la
carapate que j'ai j'ai vu j'ai constaté
qu'ils ne demandez pas mon papier et
disent ah non pardon si vous êtes vous
et allez dans une ville bombardée vous
avez trouvé à l'applaudir pour tester si
les gens vous accueillez
ya dix ans j'avais ce que je lis cette
jeunesse le public apprécie mais ça
devient drôle de nom mais et vu un homme
et c'est vous qui êtes de ces mallettes
7 6 alors que les mangas voulait
croire les vous trompez collomb je suis
atterré par les élucubrations ce
monsieur que je préfère ne pas écouter
bravo madame et j'ai une question simple
vous êtes natif d'égypte est ce que vous
auriez accepté d'être triés comme vous
êtes arrivé en france j'ai été traîné
sur wii j'ai été priés quand j'ai des
souvenirs avaient refusé est ce que vous
auriez accepté mais moi moi je ne suis
pas venu en france sur violent ni
frontière ni en tant qu il n'égale c'est
la france mais invite maison mais c'est
la vie a invité ma mère vient le défunt
de venir en france ça n'a rien à voir y
compris les congés d'été la nationalité
française il y aille à
destination jean-michel
d'ukrainiens lui doit le défendre il
vaut le budget des frontières quand on
est pas content tu n'es pas la solitude
chainel et qu'on veut rentrer en pologne
la pologne est un pays souverain qui a
le droit d'accueillir ou non
c'est
donc vous saviez vous que vous avez
violé les frontières prince du tout je
sais je suis pas mal de poids deux
mesures vous êtes fous ou arrêt c'est
vous qui êtes fous non non je suis venu
à deux poids deux mesures
almeida au couvent et vous pouvez
couvrir vos oreilles rires mais je ne
vais pas car je n'ai même pas besoin
d'en avant de venir en france j'avais on
à ma mère avait un visa j'aimerais foot
votre mère venir c'est non mais c'est
pas ça ça c'est pas gentil mais je m'en
fous
demandez vous êtes chartier
20e et les îles sakhaline 2 monsieur
haineux et racistes
[Applaudissements]
ces éléments
[Musique]
dans votre logique racialiste ça veut
dire que c'est non je ne suis pas dans
une logique en fait s'il est si friand
logique se dresser par les genres assez
bien alors non j'ai jamais été dans une
logique face à lille
ces personnes de couleur noire qui sont
refoulés à la frontière parce que ce
soit soit rien alors imaginons ils ne
sont pas ukrainien donc gommer ses
passagers dont ils ne sont pas non moi
je pense qu'ils sont en craignant sinon
ils craignent un nom ok donc vous dites
excusez moi monsieur vous n'êtes pas
ukrainien donc vous retourner sous les
bombes et on en a rien à [ __ ] en vous
pouvez mourir on en a rien à [ __ ] et
servant de relais le problème c'est
qu'il ya un problème du même nom et vous
savez que tous les pays au monde ont des
réseaux diplomatiques qui sont censé
capter la situation dans les pays où ces
diplomates sont postés d'accord donc si
vous êtes par exemple ressortissant
marocain ou sénégalais ou ivoiriens que
vous êtes dans un pays où la guerre
éclate ces pays ont des ambassades dans
le pays en guerre et donc c'est à eux
d'assurer la protection dorsale c'est
d'ailleurs à ça qu'ils servent et la
protection consulaire
c'est comme comme le protecteur de du
monde avance et le rhône et la pologne
c'est un tel cela aujourd'hui les gens
là aujourd'hui un chèque je sais que
vaut cette logique qui consiste à dire
que chaque pays protègent en priorité
ses citoyens dans dans votre dans votre
esprit mondialistes où tout le monde où
la terre entière il n'y a pas de
souveraineté et pas de nationalité ça
vous choque mais tous les pays du monde
raisonne comme ça on est chacun à huit
mois est amorcé guillaume champions
c'est une question pour jean m'bessa
donc si je comprends bien vous vous êtes
pour accueillir les réfugiés ukrainien
blanc et catholique je suis prêt mais ça
m'étonne que vous parce que vous passez
votre temps à nyon et dès que les
français l'annonçant culotté est-ce
qu'on est un peu démago non pas du tout
j'ai déjà une ronde à morges et m'a dit
ça vous me faites dire ce que j'ai pas
dis j'ai dit simple il vous le dis tout
le temps des réfugiés et craignant ne
sont pas des réfugiés comme tous ceux
qu'on a vus auparavant parce que ce sont
principalement familles des femmes des
enfants et des vieillards d'accord ce
qui n'est pas le cas encore une fois des
bateaux que l'on voit des marques et de
la méditerranée où on voit parader à mes
enfants que rarement des enfants non je
suis désolé quand un pays est en guerre
ce sont les hommes qui restent et les
femmes et les enfants qui fuient et pas
l inverse cela dans le cas de l'ukraine
nous avons de vrais réfugiés dont on
peut penser qu'ils ce qui serait là en
france à titre temporaire et non pas à
titre permanent font d'autres
anniversaires